hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Super Mario maker
I'm done with companion spring - I don't
know if I'm ever gonna return to it
frankly I don't know if I can handle it
but this one has 10 times more people
that completed it than the other one so
I hope that Ross will be merciful on my
happy place because my happy place is
not happy anymore and I'm not happy I'm
I'm okay I'm okay I calmed down I I'm
okay I can do this so with that being
said I'm gonna do this it's gonna be
great this is just a boss rush thing all
I gotta do is I got a rush the bosses
you know oh I didn't even know I could
do that well apparently I did that so
good for me I get yeah there we go okay
this is already turning out a little bit
better than the other one okay alrighty
then
okay damn it I thought that was gonna
work well that's okay oh god damn it oh
God I saw the grumps play this when it
worked out a little I was supposed to
land on that wasn't I [ __ ] me in the rat
hole this is not how this was okay that
I don't know how I do these things but
I'm doing them that's good enough for me
it's good enough for me it's good enough
good enough good enough all I need to
know is that it's good enough for me and
I'm okay why why yeah there we go
Jesus anyway
why is the wall jam not working okay so
there was I already have them already
have a shroom there so anyway my happy
place I was gonna talk about I think
okay this I am supposed to oh of course
you would
sorry I have nothing clever to say at
the moment I'm dying I'm okay
honestly guys I'm okay I don't need to
win winning is just kind of a winnings a
fool's game anyway winnings for chumps
real the thing is you know it's all
about perseverance the spirit what the
of course as soon as I actually get it
come on
anyway it's all about it's all about
having fun I think is what I mentioned
at the beginning of this episode can't
do it when there's something in my hand
of course I can't ah [ __ ] you [ __ ]
give me the shroom
okay now we got it okay now I feel good
about I forget that there's a fire
flower right there so okay first try
boink boink did it done it gone ass my
blasts just yeah I don't know what asked
my blasts means but I'm gonna put it on
a t-shirt and I'm gonna wear ask my
blast baby ask my blasts yeah that's
what I wanted to do that come on we did
it we got did it we did it we got did it
okay I didn't want to hit him on the
first try anyway that would have been
too simple what the f what the f what
the f was that it doesn't matter I'm
doing fine but I lost my fire flower
which is what I actually wanted for this
one would have been nice would have been
nice to have would have been nice but
you know it's not about having nice so
god I forgot Oh God okay I remember I
can put this on the shell turtles on the
half-shell turtles on the half-shell
baby turtles on the half-shell ate a
dick how do I beat you fire flower would
be nice I can do this
oh okay whoa go god oh god oh god oh god
okay it's okay it's okay
what yes I'm a winner I'm a winner I'm a
winner I'm a winner [ __ ] okay there we
go give me give give give give give it
to me give it to me baby give it to me
I'm right here I'm right here I want it
I want it thank you
alright bozer's being a bit of a douche
what else is no god damn it if I throw
this thank you for that Oh Frick I'm not
even gonna risk it I'm gonna kill you
straight up oh oh oh oh come on go the
other way go the other oh really really
oh god damn it stop with it no no that
is [ __ ] this such [ __ ] and you
knew it you [ __ ] know it
oh come on Oh
just give me the oh my god okay there we
thats good enough whatever well I am NOT
okay right now
[ __ ] me come on just do what I want you
to do and we'll live a happy life we'll
go to a cottage in the middle of
Nebraska not surrounded by nothingness
[ __ ] that no no no devolved into just
making noises I can't even come up with
words Oh God there we go
finally Jesus
I don't even care about cuz obviously
I'm probably gonna lose my fire flower
anyway just cuz of this [ __ ]
yeah that's em almost impossible to do
no not that's not okay
now if we could just go in here and
everything would be hunky-dory I don't
even know I have this there we go
any mini men I'm on I'm on I'm on I'm on
I'm on I'm on I'm on I'm on I'm on I'm
my boy okay from here on out it's easy
street right I'm not I'm gonna try to
wall jump anymore cuz frickin impossible
didn't thank you for dodging that right
no oh my god if you would have got
[ __ ] damn it that's so difficult it
may not look difficult but my voice is
tracking and I practically feel bats in
this is [ __ ] thank you for the boost
oh yes
right into that because who would want
to actually have some assistance again
it would have been nice to have the fire
flower but it's whatever at this point
I'll take what I can get and what I can
get is a fire flower right here I forgot
that's not where the fire flower was
that's right that's where the hammer
bros were yes I got it and you know it's
not that all of this is individually
very hard it's that all cumulatively it
takes up someone well alright I deserve
that when I stopped paying attention for
half a second so why not take a little
bit of life from me that's okay I don't
have any life left from what I've been
through in this game but whatever it's
all hunky-dory to me
hoody hard oh who do hoody the who de
bordo Han Solo okay now we got it we're
gonna get this we're gonna get this damn
it why is that one hard okay now we got
this and now if I just start come out
guns blazing oh wait this isn't the one
damn it
okay we're good we're good we're good
we're good we're good we're good we're
good
okay guns blazing yeah take that suck on
them dongs suck on my dongs dongs dongs
cuz here it's much more beneficial oh
God almost lost my fire fire god okay
hates me hates me if you can hate me
with your saucy spike I've got
protection I've got protection this is
gonna be the winner I can already tell
oh oh oh oh oh god oh no god dammit that
[ __ ]
yeah I wanna break it I won't break it
thank you all so much for watching I'm
done with this episode I'm gonna try
this one more time we'll try it one more
time let's see what happens
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video